it's been 21 years since diablo ii and
if you missed the seminal classic or are
hankering to revisit then the remaster
diablo 2 resurrected is upon us and is
coming to consoles for the first time
the classic game's got a brand new look
as well as a few tweaks and additions to
modernize the experience for a new and
returning audience so here's everything
you need to know and all the biggest
changes for more diablo and to keep up
on what's happening at activision
blizzard with regard to the ongoing
legal action taken by the california
department of fair employment and
housing make sure to subscribe
diablo 2 resurrected is the complete
edition of the original game including
the base game and its lord of
destruction expansion the most
significant change is the new visual
style which presents the game at 4k
resolution while the original was 2d the
remaster runs on a new 3d engine that
has reimagined many iconic characters
locations loot and monsters it paints
over the 2d sprites with 3d rendered
models to give it new life the original
game's cinematics and soundtrack have
also been rebuilt from the ground up but
if you still want to experience the
original diablo 2 as it was you can tap
the legacy button and instantly swap to
the classic look in real time now
playable in modern monitor resolutions
and speaking of monitors while you'll be
able to play the game on an ultra wide
it won't support the full 21.9 ultra
wide aspect ratio instead only extending
to 19.9 21 9 support was included in the
game's technical alpha but was removed
because it broke the game specifically
playing at an ultra-wide aspect ratio
made it so that players could attack
from further ranges than the game was
designed for enemies targeted from the
extended range ultrawide monitors
provide simply failed to recognize they
were being attacked and as a result
didn't react on a mechanical level
resurrected doesn't change much of the
core gameplay from the original game
which was the intent according to
blizzard however there are updates to
the game that aim to make the dungeon
crawling and power growth less tedious
for your chosen class like auto gold
pickup more helpful tutorial tips and
reminders to use your skill points you
can toggle these on and off at will the
biggest change that relates to the flow
and management of loot is the new shared
stash box allowing you to easily share
items with your different characters in
the original game if you wanted to share
items amongst all your characters you
would have to find an empty server drop
your gear swap over to a different
character and pick up the items with
them to do so this new mechanic doesn't
substantially change the game but it
does make things a bit more manageable
for dedicated players with regard to
ladders blizzard revealed that in order
to ensure server stability at launch the
game's first ladder season will come
shortly after the game's release but
won't be available on day one and that
formerly ladder exclusive unique items
rune words and recipes will be included
in non-ladder multiplayer and single
player for the first time ladder seasons
usually last around 6 months and require
new characters to be created
and there are ladders for both normal
and hardcore aka permadeath characters
but of course one of the biggest changes
is that the game is available on
consoles for the first time in regards
to how resurrected handles displaying
and mapping abilities blizzard took cues
from its console port of diablo 3
showing certain abilities in a tray on
the lower part of the hud the game also
controls differently on console you have
direct control of your character's
movement with your thumbstick whereas on
pc you click on a destination and your
character will wander over looting is
also different compared to the pc
version instead of holding down a button
to see loot on the ground and then
clicking to pick it up the console
version automatically displays items on
the ground for players nearby simply
walk over items slowly to pick them up
diablo 2 resurrected will still have
online multiplayer along with bringing
back eight player games resurrected's
online infrastructure has been updated
to protect players against cheaters and
those looking to hack however it has
been confirmed that the remaster will
not have cross play amongst the
different platforms tcp ip multiplayer
which allowed players to connect via lan
or other peer-to-peer connections
instead of official servers will not be
present in the remaster and blizzard
cites security risks as the reason
you'll be limited to dedicated blizzard
servers when you play online it will
also allow for cross progression meaning
if you've been hanging onto your pc save
file for 20 years your local single
player save will work
back at blizzcon earlier this year
blizzard spoke about the different
lessons learned from the making of
warcraft 3 reforged which was released
to a mixed reception from fans much a
fan disappointment for warcraft 3 came
from blizzard using the remaster to
replace the original game on battle.net
making it the only way to play the last
strategy game in the warcraft series in
our talk with blizzard at the time the
studio stated that they plan to keep the
original version of diablo 2 on
battle.net which will be playable
alongside the remaster while resurrected
will keep the classic game and visuals
in its legacy mode players who are still
used to the original can opt to play
that instead
the remaster of diablo 2 is coming from
both blizzard entertainment and
developer vicarious visions the latter
previously worked on the crash bandicoot
insane trilogy remaster and 2020's tony
hawk pro skater 1 and 2. so the studio
has quite the pedigree when it comes to
updating classic games along with
handling the remaster vicarious visions
is also behind the process of bringing
diablo 2 to consoles which as i
mentioned earlier marks the game's first
appearance away from pc
diablo 2 resurrected is the first major
game release from blizzard as parent
company activision blizzard continues to
address allegations from a state of
california lawsuit that's accusing
parent company activision blizzard of
fostering a frat boy culture of
harassment and discrimination against
women thousands of employees signed an
open letter condemning how the company
responded to the lawsuit and staged a
massive walk out on july 28 2021 the
california department of fair employment
and housing later updated its lawsuit
accusing the company of destroying
evidence pertinent to the investigation
following those allegations numerous
veteran blizzard employees left the
company with president j alan brack
stepping down and jen o'neil and mikey
barra taking over parent company
activision blizzard is also facing a
separate lawsuit from employees which
alleges that the company is using
coercive actions to prevent
organizational efforts to improve
working conditions it's also facing a
third lawsuit this time from its
shareholders who allege that the company
failed to notify them about the
department of fair employment and
housing's two-year investigation the sec
has also launched an investigation over
the company's handling of employees
allegations of sexual misconduct and
workplace discrimination and has
subpoenaed activision blizzard and
multiple senior executives including ceo
bobby kotick
[Music]
there's a link in the description where
we're keeping a timeline of all events
to do with the activision blizzard legal
action so make sure to keep an eye on
gamespot to keep up to date
[Music]
[Music]
you